[Music]
on this Monday night Nova scotia's
tragic storm it's a heartbreaking day
for our for our Province the discovery
made in the search for four missing
people and the destruction from
torrential rains and raging flood waters
while Greece's prime minister says his
country is at war with fire
Israel's controversial judicial reforms
become a reality
the Uproar unrest and fears of what's
next
widening access to reproductive Health
Care a push for Universal coverage of
contraception in Canada and the big
business of barberheimer I bought my
tickets months ago the Blockbusters
bringing people back to the box office
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
is news in Nova Scotia tonight about the
four people whose Vehicles were
submerged in the unprecedented flash
flooding over the weekend RCMP say they
have recovered the body of a 52-year-old
man in West hands and human remains have
been found in another area Nova scotia's
Premier calls it a heartbreaking day
we can rebuild roads and bridges and
buildings but we can't bring people back
and the Legacy for these floods will be
the um incredibly tragic uh loss of life
much of the province has been dealing
with catastrophic flooding caused by
Heavy Rain two children and one youth
remain unaccounted for tonight and the
damage to roads and bridges is still
being assessed Mike Armstrong has our
top story tonight
draining for Searchers both physically
and emotionally the four people swept
away Friday night disappeared in the
same area at any one time more than 60
people have been out looking for them in
the hot sun there's multiple members in
full body wetsuits and uh protective
equipment in that area and that heat is
definitely taking a toll
the water levels are still high in some
places but it's the sort of flooding
people are used to in the spring what
happened this weekend was different
swather precipitation that moved over
Nova Scotia dumped 200 millimeters of
rain on some areas what would normally
fall over an entire summer dropped in
half a day
Premier says just one fire department
responded to more than a hundred rescue
calls a lot of people stepped up and
their efforts saved lives for sure I was
just here by myself with my friend and
our two toddlers Janelle bonus knew
quickly when the flood waters started to
rise Friday she had to get out because
what she didn't know was where the water
would stop we can see there that where
the water line is so literally to here
yeah this is this is the laundry room
[Music]
so then that was the playroom so we had
a bar
um we had a coach ripping everything out
and repairing their home will cost the
bonus family tens of thousands of
dollars which raises the question of
insurance uh we're just waiting to see
what's covered
that's a tense time yeah
the storm damaged or destroyed more than
50 roads and 25 Bridges some have been
able to reopen for others it will take
longer this is the main rail line from
the port of Halifax to the rest of
Canada CN says it had preemptively
closed a section of tracks Friday
because there were warnings about flash
flooding
Crews were emptying this sewage pump
station Monday after it was flooded and
the pumps were damaged people are being
told to avoid the water at the local
Lake and are being asked to reduce how
much they flush down their drains until
the system can be brought back online
Mike Armstrong Global News Halifax
NBC there was no reprieve for
firefighters hundreds of wildfires are
still burning and they've moved South
and out of control fire is now burning
near Kamloops more than 500 properties
are under some form of of an evacuation
alert because of the Ross Moore Lake
Fire it doubled in size in 24 hours the
city is reminding people to be ready to
leave at a moment's notice British
Columbia is in the midst of its worst
Wildfire season on record about 1.5
million hectares of land has burned so
far
and in Greece where extreme heat has
lingered for weeks now authorities are
scrambling to carry out the largest fire
evacuations in that country's history
firefighters are battling to control
blazes on the island of Roads a popular
vacation spot about 19 thousand people
most of them tourists have been forced
to flee people are reporting chaotic
scenes in some cases evacuees crowded to
board small boats arriving to take them
off the beach
hell on a
um never thought I'd be caught up in
something like that there's there's
someone's going to end up dying out
there seriously that there are thousands
of people that are still out there
one death has been confirmed on the
island of Evia which is issued an
evacuation order along with the island
of Corfu on Greece's Mainland
firefighters are fending off a growing
Blaze near Athens the Greek Prime
Minister says the country is at war with
fire and several European countries have
deployed emergency crews to help
well it is no secret Canada spends
billions on subsidies to the oil and gas
sector and for years there have been
promises to reduce or eliminate them
today the federal government revealed
its plan to phase them out as Mackenzie
gray reports critics call it a half
measure and exactly how much money and
subsidies will be eliminated will be
hard to track
their protest Stephen gilbeau are used
to even when he's meeting a key
government promise I'm absolutely
thrilled today to be able to announce
the publication of the framework and
guidelines for eliminating inefficient
fossil fuel subsidies in Canada the plan
first pledged at the G20 in 2009 has six
different exemptions that would let
Federal subsidies continue including for
projects with indigenous ownership and
proposals with a credible plan to
achieve net zero emissions by 2030. we
are heavily concerned about the criteria
that have been that have been developed
there are significant loopholes as well
those loopholes current federal tax
credits for oil and gas exploration
won't be changed and Crown corporations
like export development Canada aren't
subject to these rules from 2018 to 2020
EDC averaged 13 billion dollars a year
in support for oil and gas companies a
decision the environment Minister
defended they've reduced substantially
those fossil fuels cities by billions of
dollars while increasing by several
billions of dollars their support for
clean technology and there was
disappointment from the Liberals
political Partners phasing out public
fossil fuel financing is a part of the
government's deal with the NDP we can't
take baby steps when we are facing
wildfires and extreme flooding and heat
domes despite not saying how much less
oil and gas companies would get from the
federal government some environmental
groups are still applauding the move the
impacts that we are experiencing across
the country today are the result of the
activities from fossil fuel companies
they should not be receiving the
transfers of public dollars to fuel the
activities causing the climate crisis we
reached out to a number of oil and gas
organizations but they declined our
request for an interview but they didn't
seem too concerned about the new rules
Donna one of the organizations labeled
it as meh
all right Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you a shake-up of federal cabinet
ministers is expected this week prime
minister Justin Trudeau is in private
meetings today and several ministers
have had their agendas cleared mental
health and addictions Minister Carolyn
Bennett confirmed this morning she will
not be seeking re-election she is among
several ministers expected to be
replaced in cabinet and what One Source
tells Global News could be a significant
Shuffle it's expected to take place
Wednesday
a 28 year old Edmonton man arrested by
British police at Heathrow Airport in
London last week has now been charged
under the UK's terrorism act the British
crown prosecution service says Khalid
Hussein was charged with membership in a
prescribed organization in a statement
Global Affairs Canada says only that it
is aware a Canadian citizen in the UK
has been charged with a
terrorism-related offense Consular
officials are providing Consular
assistance the man is charged alongside
56-year-old British preacher anjem
choudhary who the prosecution claims
spoke weekly to online groups giving
lectures on the establishment of an
Islamic State in Britain and how to
radicalize people
Israel masses of people are blocking
streets tonight and authorities are
using water cannon to try to disperse
them the people are Furious the Israeli
Parliament pushed through a law earlier
today limiting the Supreme Court's
ability to overturn decisions made by
government ministers the U.S Israel's
closest Ally is disappointed to the
White House saying it's unfortunate that
the vote took place today with the
slimmest possible majority prime
minister Benjamin netanyahu's coalition
government is the most right-wing and
religiously conservative in Israel's
history and this is just the first in a
package of planned judicial reforms
Crystal gemancing Reports on the fury
and what demonstrators are planning next
unrest in Anger as Israeli lawmakers
undertake a seismic shift in the
nation's Democratic Foundation we were
left with no choice but to go to
non-violent disobedience
and we're here to protect our democracy
with our brother with our bodies
demonstrators chained themselves to
whatever they could including each other
blocking the road to the knesset ahead
of Monday's vote to remove the Supreme
Court's ability to strike down
government rules based on reasonability
tens of thousands marched on Jerusalem
I'm here for three days protesting and
do everything I can
[Applause]
inside the Israeli Parliament the
opposition yelled shame and walked out
Benjamin netanyahu's government rests on
the shoulders of a far-right coalition
giving his side the numbers to pass the
contentious bills devoted friends Canada
and the U.S urged the Israeli Prime
Minister to seek broader consensus
before going ahead with the reforms how
far is the degradation of the Judiciary
in Israel going to go it is not yet
clear
the legislation is just one element of a
larger judicial overhaul package put on
hold in the face of fierce opposition
though Netanyahu also faced pressure to
act or risk losing his Coalition he now
says he's willing to discuss the next
phases
as night fell more demonstrations and
more clashes with police this time in
Tel Aviv both sides used the Israeli
flag as their symbol AS judicial reforms
have divided the nation the issue has
even resulted in thousands of Israeli
Defense Force reservists threatening to
not show up for Duke
a weaker Supreme Court could make it
easier for the government to build more
Israeli settlements in occupy
territories something netanyahu's
far-right Coalition has already pledged
to do the change could also help the
Prime Minister he still faces corruption
charges an opposition party has already
filed a court Challenge on the judicial
reforms legislation Donna all right
crystal commencing in London tonight
thanks Russian authorities accuse
Ukraine of launching a drone attack on
Moscow early this morning moscow's mayor
says two drones struck non-residential
buildings near the center of the city
there is no serious damage Russia's
defense Ministry calls it a terrorist
act and says the drones were intercepted
and then crashed yesterday Ukraine's
government vowed to retaliate for a
Russian missile attack on the Black Sea
city of Odessa and the U.N is calling on
Russia to resume a deal that allows
grain to be shipped from Ukraine's black
seed ports after Russia halted it last
week with determination of the Black Sea
initiative the most vulnerable will pay
the highest price as when food prices
rise everybody pays for it we're already
seeing the negative effect on global
wheat and corn prices which hurts
everyone but this is especially
devastating for vulnerable countries
struggling to feed their people
the Black Sea initiative was brokered by
the U.N and turkey as a way to keep
grain flowing to developing nations the
U.S justice department is suing the
Texas governor Greg Abbott over a
floating barrier on the Rio Grande River
intended to deter migrants Texas
installed a line of wrecking ball-sized
boys along the river to stop people from
Crossing into the U.S from Mexico the
lawsuit asks a court to force Texas to
remove the barrier the Biden
Administration says the floating
barricade raises humanitarian and
environmental concerns it's the latest
escalation of a Texas border security
operation that includes razor wire
fencing and arresting migrants on
trespassing charges
British Columbia does it now there are
called for the federal government to
follow suits and provide Universal
coverage for contraception coming up
we'll talk to the doctor behind the
petition
[Music]
there is a debate underway in Canada
about universal access to free
contraception right now BC provides it
but in many provinces it depends on
whether you have insurance Sarah often
speaks with a Calgary doctor trying to
change that she's launching a federal
petition for Universal coverage
it's just like the three four days and
then you're good but is that typically
like not the case it's a conversation
this Calgary doctor is trying to reframe
birth control she says isn't about sex
but about having a reproductive life
plan when she believes every Canadian
should have reliable access to in Canada
today there exists in inequity right in
individuals being able to access that
life of self-determination but for now
that access depends on where a person
lives the type of Clinic they use and
whether they have insurance BC passed
legislation this spring to cover the
cost of birth control pills
contraceptive injections iuds subdermal
implants and emergency contraception
medication and while Dr tour would like
to see other provinces follow suit what
she's really pushing for is a federal
policy for Universal coverage I'm a
really strong believer that Reproductive
Rights are human rights simply put right
and they're just too important to be
left at the whim of changing provincial
governments there's an economic argument
to be made too public policy agency
action Canada suggests every dollar
invested in birth control saves more
than seven dollars in managing
unintended pregnancies as part of a
statement the office of Canada's
Ministry of Health says everyone has the
right to safe and consistent access to
sexual and reproductive Health Care here
this is why we withhold transfers to
provinces that fail to make abortion and
sexual and reproductive health services
safe and available and while that's the
case now some feminist Scholars suggest
that could change based on the ideology
of whichever party is in power currently
the federal government
has both withheld and clawed back Health
transfers because of a lack of access to
abortion in particular and other forms
of reproductive health and so that's
that's great but again it's
it's overly politicized the NDP has long
pushed for Universal coverage and as
part of their supply and confidence deal
with the Liberals the federal government
has until June of 2025 to develop a list
of essential medications to be covered
under a national pharmacare plan some
suggest birth control could be a
symbolic First Step Sarah often Global
News Calgary
I had the search for possible unmarred
graves in the basement of a Catholic
Church in Manitoba
an excavation is getting underway at a
Catholic church near a former
residential school in Manitoba a search
using ground penetrating radar formed 14
14 anomalies beneath the church's dirt
floor on the First Nation about 400
kilometers Northwest of Winnipeg
indicating the possibility of unmarked
Graves Melissa ridgeen takes us to the
community
it began with a sunrise ceremony at Our
Lady of Seven Sorrows church we have to
start our processes based on our our
culture based on the ceremonies that we
know how to create safe space we create
safe space with ceremony so that people
can come into the space and feel
comfortable and feel like they're being
taken care of community and church
leaders alongside forensic
anthropologists they're all small steps
that people take you know along that
road of
reconciling with the past and building
relationships with one another this team
from Brandon University will search down
here under the church my grandmother
came for three years and she would tell
us stories too like when we were little
kids and scary stories ground
penetrating radar found 14 spots of
Interest under the basement of the
church adjacent to the Pine Creek
residential school that operated here
from the late 1800s until 1969. we'll
also be looking for any right are there
any animal bones are there potential
archaeological artifacts or cultural
materials so all of that will be mapped
and documented and photographed the team
will set up tomorrow and carefully start
digging under each of these markers it's
expected to take four weeks to complete
the search RCMP are watching this
project as it unfolds Chief Derek
nepenak says whatever this excavation in
this church basement does or doesn't
reveal it's about healing and moving
forward it's to clear up questions and
doubts
[Music]
research and assurance that this
generation will know the truth of
whatever this church holds
my method for unknown children resting
somewhere at this site and for the 21
the national Center For Truth and
Reconciliation lists as having died here
while attending
Melissa Ridge in Global News minigun
zibi anishinabe First Nation Manitoba
box office boom next how movies about
Barbie and the atom bomb are boosting
the film industry
[Music]
before they were even released they were
being hyped as summer Blockbusters and
all the promotion worked the film's
Barbie and Oppenheimer couldn't be more
different from each other and yet
they're released through tens of
thousands of people to theaters to see
both of them back to back as Eric
Sorensen explains the barberheimer
Bonanza couldn't have come at a better
time for Hollywood
so which movie were they dressed up for
Oppenheimer Oppenheimer yeah yeah of
course of course they're kidding about
that no
but on the most hyped movie weekend in
years I am very excited hi Barbie hi
Barbie Barbie's Canadian content
notwithstanding it's almost too polite
the berbenheimer phenomenon couldn't be
more quintessentially American Barbie
symbol of America's creative fantasy and
Oppenheimer America's real and
destructive power all America's
industrial mine and scientific
innovation connected here you guys
everything about dying
the juxtaposition just so ludicrous it
brought out memes and t-shirts the
Barbie font and then obviously the uh
the mushroom cloud representing you know
oppenheimer's destructive work what
mushroomed were audience numbers in
theaters the North American box office
saw barbie bring in over 200 million
dollars Canadian Oppenheimer more than
100 million the opening weekend topped
320 million dollars and globally more
than half a billion there's never been a
one-two opening weekend punch like it
Barbie was the biggest opening ever for
a film directed by a woman Greta Gerwig
and Oppenheimer broke records for an
R-rated biographical drama it did
incredibly well even better than they
were expecting
but will it last striking Hollywood
screenwriters have been joined by actors
on the picket line soon enough the
upsurge in audiences could tumble if new
movie production remains at a standstill
movies don't write themselves you have
to have actors in front of the camera so
this is going to be very important that
this gets resolved the sooner the better
hey leaving Barbie Girls more women
turned out for Barbie more men watched
Oppenheimer I bought my tickets months
ago a fusion of movie themes
the 1940s Adam Bomb and the 1950s Barbie
doll the unlikeliest cultural chain
reaction in American history Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is this pod or Squadron of
pelicans in Lockport Manitoba thanks for
watching bye-bye
[Music]